m
[Musique]
non
il ya des chansons qui ont marqué dont
était passé et depuis longtemps ce soir
on va retourner loin en arrière 1966
l'année où tout le monde chantait le
même refrain celui que vous avez entendu
la poupée qui fait non
un véritable ver d'oreille adapté au
québec par les sultans voici louis
philippe ouimet
55 capital à ce qu'on vous parle encore
de la poupée qui fait non ben oui un
reste un saint steinitz quête du beau
cinéma vocable on peut d antan chuchoter
en arrière et je pensais le chanteur 18
ans surtout
[Musique]
en 1966 pourquoi vous avez décidé
d'interpréter la poupée qui fait non de
michel polnareff parce que mes sources
ouais c'était une idée du producteur
la compagnie disque
est-ce que vous l'aimiez cette chanson
là non violent pour que ça soit pas tout
ils font c'est ça qui nous aimons ces
six autres quoique on peut remercier la
compagnie de disques c'est ce qui nous
est mise à mal
parce que ça joue tout le temps c'était
vraiment ça les mêmes entendu h au même
moment donné comme on dit non et à rots
la tonne était vraiment et on se pose a
soulevé un intérêt généraliser les jours
nous disait qu'on était le club le plus
populaire des années en 1966 était de
tous les groupes qui avaient cessé ce
que les journaux d'hier une partie de
succès des sultans c'est que beaucoup
souhaitent pas mal boban je pense tu as
eu l'idée du producteur c'était de
d'associer maintenant une chanson que
bell fans avec des bots brume et notre
jeu pour faire en sorte que les filles
vont vendre ont connecté il ôte et je
pense au pire c'est tout le monde qui
connecté
[Musique]
on veut
cinquante cinq ans plus tard elle doit
encore capable de chanter la poupée qui
fait non on on peut essayer mais on
essaye même genre 11h le matin rapporté
mike starr ok attention aucune fausse
note c'est parti
le nom
la journée elle venir
mail
manger
[Musique]
vous avez passé le test merci beaucoup
avait apaisé